sin dar mayores detalles el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador confirmó que
a propuesta de noruega méxico será la
sede para el diálogo entre el gobierno
de nicolás maduro al que nunca le retiro
el reconocimiento y la oposición de
venezuela maduro ha dicho que para
cualquier negociación con el bloque
opositor sus voceros son el líder de la
asamblea nacional jorge rodríguez y el
gobernador del estado de miranda héctor
rodríguez por lo que se esperaría la
presencia de ambos por la contraparte
estaría presente un representante de
cada uno de los cuatro partidos
opositores el gobierno de maduro busca
que estados unidos levanten las
sanciones económicas mientras que la
oposición pretende conseguir garantías
democráticas para el próximo proceso
electoral la fecha tentativa de arranque
de estas charlas es el 13 de agosto
aunque esto estaban por confirmarse
méxico tiene tradición de mediador y un
antecedente importante son los acuerdos
de chapultepec firmados en la ciudad de
méxico y que en 1992 pusieron fin a 12
años de guerra civil en el salvador